bo
is in melbourne florida hi bo how are
you
hey dave hey rachel i am so happy to be
speaking to both of you
you do what's up hey so um
yeah just some quick background life is
pretty good
overall i say i'm debt free got an
emergency fund i'm
you know three weeks into a new job
which i
am learning a lot in and i've really
wanted to do for a long time
how old are you um 28 i'll be 29 in
september
good for you congratulations thank you
thank you so much yeah
um so but with all that i'm uh
my parents bring up every so often it's
not the first time that
this has come up too just the topic of
well
you're doing all this great things but
you got to think about getting a credit
card for whenever you want to
buy a home and everything too and um i'm
just
it's not the first time it's come up and
i'm just trying to look for some
ideas or pointers on how to you know
respectfully
you know have this um talk to them about
this if this ever comes up again because
i've made it clear that i'm
following your plan and that i don't
want to go into debt or use one and that
you know the other thing they bring up
too is well if you get a home without a
credit score you'll
have an insane amount of interest or you
may pay more interest they may want to
use so it might be good to have it
anyway
so that's the main point that they're
bringing up and
well i'll start and just tell you that
the information that they have
is not accurate that's just not
that's just simply not true okay um
tens of thousands of people get
mortgages every year that have zero
credit score
uh you have to go and they do not get
penalized with a higher interest rate
they get the exact same interest rate
uh and all you've got to do is go to
churchill mortgage that we've endorsed
here for 20 plus years on the air
and it's called manual underwriting and
they check to see that you have a job
and they check to see that you have a
down payment and um
they check to see that you don't have a
bunch of delinquencies on your credit
but if you have a zero credit score and
there's no activity on your credit at
all
you can get a home mortgage without a
higher interest rate
and um and you can get a home mortgage
uh
you know you have to been steady on the
job and you have to have a reasonable
down payment but it's like they're
actually checking to see if you're
breathing before they make the loan in
other words
and that's how it's done and so i don't
know where mom and dad got their
information
but they're wrong and i think bo when a
lot of people talk about
getting a house without a credit score
there's some people that don't even
realize that you can like some people
are like oh no you have to have a credit
score
then there's those that have information
that's not correct
and that floats around a lot in that
world so they've probably read some
article or heard a friend talk about it
or
something but i think you having facts
on your side
is is probably the best bet and i mean
it's
you could you know you almost frame it
like i appreciate that you guys are
concerned
like i appreciate that um but what
you're concerned about is something that
is unnecessary because
of x y and z i'm gonna you know when
it's time to buy home and save my down
payments
and this is the you know this is the
route that i've choose that i've chosen
to you know if you wanted to you could
actually call churchill mortgage and
just say you know i talked to a mortgage
company
and they told me they were able to do it
and it's one that works through the dave
ramsey organization and they're
you know they're endorsed by them and so
they've they've learned how to do it a
lot of mortgage companies don't know how
to do a mortgage without a credit score
the mortgage business has been dumbed
down to where a monkey can make a loan
if the monkey can identify the number on
the credit score
you got the loan right that's all it is
and so
there's lots of problems with that for
the mortgage business but um
but you know when i got my real estate
license a thousand years ago in 1978 at
18 years old
the only way you could get a mortgage
was they actually did
underwriting on the loan meaning they
did a vod and verify
you didn't fill out a form of
verification of deposit on your
down payment and a voe a verification of
your employment
and they made sure you were breathing
and made sure that you know you didn't
have
outstanding warrants for your arrest and
other stuff you know i mean just
just basically looking to see if you
wanted to make a loan to this person
instead of just looking at one number
and going you got the loan
right and so uh that but the business
has changed and it is largely done on
credit scores now
so um a lot of people just don't know
the information and so
um and then the other thing that happens
too here is
um this is a bit of a boundary
conversation with your mom and dad
okay uh this is not a conversation i
would have with one of my grown kids
even if they were doing something i
thought was completely wrong
i mean they're still preaching to you
with their parent voice
is what you used a while ago you don't
get to do that anymore when your kids
are grown when you're 29 and you're
paying your own bills
you have to treat them like an adult and
stuff
and so if i had winston and rachel were
doing something that was out of line i
would not come in and go you're out of
line
and use my dad's voice i would come in
and go
guys i don't understand this and i've
got a question about this and i'm
worried about this and what do you think
about this and i would ask some
questions that way
instead of coming in going you need to
get a credit card because you're you're
like
12 years old and i'm you're going to do
what i tell you to do
and so that's the that you don't use the
dad voice on your grown kids it doesn't
work
unless your grown kids are wimps and so
and you're not a wimp
you're a 28 year old stud so you know
you just be kind to your mom and dad as
rachel said be respectful
thankful for um
you know your interest and your concern
i talked to churchill mortgage and it
turns out i don't have to have a credit
card
and i'm really convicted dad about not
falling into this debt trap that all of
america has fallen into
and i'm convinced that becoming wealthy
is easier if i don't have payments and
so i'm just not going to fall into the
trap of fault chasing a false god called
fico
i'm not going to worship at the altar of
the great fico he is not my provider oh
fico thank you we bring you offerings of
interest
so that you can give us good things like
a home i'm not worshiping at this altar
and you know you don't be smart i like
sarcastic like me you can be kind and
nice and respectful
yeah and to your parents you know their
perspective is they may never have
thought about this like there's people
you know obviously
uh millions and millions of americans
who don't know and they don't follow
this stuff so
you can enlighten them as well yeah but
i mean it's like i was talking to a
friend of yours the other day
uh here in the building and um uh she
was telling me about
you know five years ago when they first
got married the mother-in-law would come
in
and uh would be upset if they weren't
coming to their house for thanksgiving
and you know was like going to tell
everybody what to do
and this is a grown woman she's talking
to and the daughter-in-law said
well no we're not going to be there on
thanksgiving we're going to our parents
on thanksgiving next year we're coming
to your house we do every other
and that's what we do and this woman
demanded that they were at her house
every thanksgiving and there was no
alternative and you couldn't
and it was not leaving room for the
grown child to make a decision your
daughter-in-law to make their own
decision
and she said well of course we're not
doing that and i thought that was an
interesting thing
of course i'm not getting a credit card
and it wasn't like i'm
mad at you or something but of course i
wouldn't do that you know it's just i
thought that was a great answer it's a
different different
a different position to take with the
parent or the parent in law
in terms of the way the conversation
goes and so forth